- Good morning Believe nation,
today's message is, give it your all.
Over to you Jeremy Lin.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Enspresso keep me going
- [Jeremy] It's easy to dream big.
There's the initial
excitement, raw passion,
high hopes, and you put
in everything you have
to pursue your dream.
But inevitably the hits will come.
(upbeat music)
You get knocked down, you get back up.
You get knocked down
again, and get back up.
But the criticism keeps coming.
The hard work doesn't
seem to be paying off.
One unmet expectation after another
leads to disappointment, discouragement,
and even worse, doubt.
Maybe they're right.
Maybe I'll never be who
I thought I would be.
So what will I do?
I'll work harder than I ever have before.
I'll work on my weaknesses,
and refine my strengths.
Give more even after I
thought I gave it my all.
- Chances are you're
going to quit too soon.
Chances are you're going to
stop just as you're about
to make your big breakthrough.
Chances are you're going
to regret not saying yes
and not continuing on.
I've told this story a number of times,
but the toughest decision I
ever had to make in my life
was when I was in University.
I had to decide between
the high paying job
I thought I always wanted,
and my business that was sucking,
that I was making $300 a month at,
and I couldn't get the momentum
that I was looking for.
And the easy, safe, practical thing to do
would have been to take the job,
but I felt like I didn't
give my all to my business.
And I needed to give it
a little bit more time.
Just so that I would know.
Just so that I would know if
this thing would work or not.
And so I decided to take a year off,
while some of my friends
are off doing, you know
traveling the world and
going off and exploring.
I said, you know what, I'm
going to take one year,
and I'm going to give everything
I have to this business.
And I'm going to see
if I can make it work.
And it may not work,
the odds are that it's not going to work.
Most businesses don't work,
and up until that point,
everything that I've done
had shown that my business
was not working, but I still felt like
I had more gas in the tank.
I still felt like even
though I gave it a lot,
I had not given my all,
and I needed to know.
I needed to know, I could
deal with it not working out,
and me walking away
knowing that that's it,
I gave it everything I
had, there was nothing else
that I left on the table.
That was the best that I could have done.
If I did that, and it
didn't work, I'm good.
But if I didn't do it, if
you don't give it your all,
if you don't push yourself
to the absolute max,
and it doesn't work out, you will forever
look back and think,
maybe it could have worked.
That's the rest of your life
that you're dealing with.
And I don't want that to be your story.
I don't want you to look back on your life
and regret not having done more,
not having pushed harder.
Because that pain is for
the rest of your life.
That pain is immense, it's huge.
Versus the short term pain
of whatever you have to do
right now to give it your all,
to push a little harder, right.
To push through those extra
hours, to push through those
extra sets, to push
through that extra work.
It's painful, it sucks,
but it's nothing compared
to the lifetime of pain and
regret that is ahead of you
if you don't give it your all.
So if you're on the verge
of quitting something,
a relationship, a business,
a partnership, a customer.
If you're on the verge
of quitting something,
maybe the answer is to quit,
but I would ask yourself,
am I going to regret
walking away from this?
Did I give this situation everything I had
so that I'm confident that walking away
is the right thing to do.
It's not just the easy thing to do,
it's the right thing to do
because you gave it your all.
Don't quit too soon,
don't quit just before
you make your big breakthrough.
Quit after you've given it your all.
So the question of the
day today is I'm curious,
what percentage, out of
100 words, given everything
you've got, 100%, out of
that, where do you fall?
What are you giving to
your business right now?
Be honest, it's great to say 110%,
you can't go over 100%.
100% is the max, you're
not playing at your max.
Be honest, where are you
right now, percentage wise?
I'm curious to find out, leave it down
in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Nasr Leon,
thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, I really, really,
really appreciate your support.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you, I hope
you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word is,
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Enspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Enspresso keep me going
- Hey Believe nation, thank
you so much for watching.
If you want to learn
more about this subject,
get a little bit deeper on it,
I'm going to share some extra bonus clips
that I hope you'll enjoy.
- How do you want to be
remembered as a football player,
as a person these last
22 years and everything
that you've achieved.
As someone who did achieve a lot,
what's most important to you?
- I just want people to see me
as a hard working footballer,
someone that's passionate about the game,
and someone that every time
I stepped on the pitch,
I've given everything
that I have because that's
how I feel going in to games.
At the end of my career,
that's how I look back on it
and hope people will see me.
Because I think over the years it's been,
you know my life and my
career, people have obviously
looked at certain other
things that have gone on
throughout my career and I think sometimes
that's overshadowed what
I've done on the pitch
or what I've achieved on the pitch.
And that's as much as I say
that that doesn't hurt me,
of course it does, you
know at the end of the day,
I'm a footballer that's
played for some of the biggest
clubs in the world, played
with some of the best
players in the world,
played under some of the
biggest and best managers, and achieved
almost everything in football.
And I think of course
it hurts when people,
not question it, but
think about other things,
and to come to the end of my career now,
and look back and say
you know I've achieved
everything with every
club that I've played for.
I've played for my country 115 times,
been runner up twice
world player of the year
to amazing footballers,
I'm very proud of that.
- I love how forward
this record, you had fans
actually do little videos and talked about
what they were brave enough to do in life.
So for you, what was
the moment you realized
you were brave enough to kind
of just do this fulltime,
and just go right after your passion?
- Ooo, you know, I think it's
once I discovered YouTube.
I mean I had already been
going for it with full force,
you know, but I was
kind of, well wondering
if had what it took to make it,
and I was really
discouraged at times because
everywhere I went I
just kept being told no,
you're not good enough, and that can be
really discouraging.
It's like even though I was going for it,
I was kind of like in the back of my mind,
just really scared, like
am I going to make it?
I don't know, and then
when I finally discovered
YouTube, and I put up my first video,
I just felt so empowered and so excited
because I was like whoa,
finally something is working.
And that's when I was like I'm going to,
you know I don't know how
this is going to work out,
but I'm going to chase this
with everything I've got,
and that's when I was like boom.
- So success is not based on genetics.
It's not based on how nice his car is.
It's not based on how pretty my face is.
How small my nose may need to look.
You know, whether or not
I'm the right complexion.
I have an eight inch scar
down the side of my face,
but I have a camera in front
of me more often than not.
Which just means that
you know if you work hard
and your work is recognized,
you know the sky's the limit.
So for those people out
there that think they're ugly
and everything, I'm going
to hold it down for you.
But more importantly, you
can still be a success.
For all those people who
think well I'm too short,
well, I'm going to hold it down for you.
And more importantly you
can still be a success.
Find the things that you're excited about
and that you can give your all
and work really hard towards attaining.
String those days with efficiency,
and action together,
and success can happen.